يتزايد الطلب على المنتجات المحليه
الجزائريه في قطاع الانشاءات الى مستويات
قياسيه هذا بعد ان اقرت الحكومه خطه
للتخلي عن مواد البناء المستورده بدا
الامر بالاسمنت والحديد والخزف وتوسع هذا
الاستخدام ليشمل حصى الخرسانه والدهن وكذا
تجهيزات الكهرباء والتدفئه
المؤسسات الجزائريه في مجال البناء عامه
من حوالي 2019 الى يومنا هذا ورايا رايحه
اكثر واكثر اي تعتمد تقريبا
95% على المنتوجات المحليه سواء من ناحيه
النوعيه سواء من ناحيه الوفره سوى من
ناحيه الثمن يبلغ عدد المواد المستورده
الخاضعه للرسوم الاضافيه نحو 2006 مئه
وتبرر الحكومه خيارها بمحاربه من تسميهم
المستوردين الوهميين هذا التوجه منح
الفرصه لانتعاش اعمال الاف الشركات
المحليه لكنه يثير من حين لاخر اختلالات
في السوق سواء من حيث وفره المعروض احيانا
او ارتفاع الاسعار دون مبرر واضح
تتراوح الرسوم على السلع المستورده
الخاضعه للقيود ما بين 30 ومئتين في المئه
لكن تقرر في الاونه الاخيره تحرير استيراد
المواد التي لا يغطيها الانتاج المحلي
بعدما بات ارتفاع اسعار السلع الاستهلاكيه
حاله مزمنه ومستعصيه على الحل
الاستيراد منع لايقاف النزيف العمله
الصعبه من الخزينه العموميه واستيراد كل
ما لا ينفع المواطن الجزائري تواجه
الجزائر تحديا في لجم الاسعار الجامحه
ورضع الاحتكار ورغم الزيادات الاخيره في
اجور الموظفين فان التضخم استمر في تقويض
القدره الشرائيه للمواطنين
رغم اهميه تراجع قيمه الواردات بنحو 25
مليار دولار في السنتين الاخيرتين الا ان
هذا التوجه ادى الى ارتفاع اسعار السلع
المنتجه محليا مع زياده الطلب ومحدوديه
المعروض واختفاء بعضه بسبب المضاربه
الجزيره الجزائر